I I mentioned this is national chili day
and Paulie went back and found one of
our favorite clips from the office where
Brian Bumgardner Kevin on the office
brings in his chick can we play this and
then Fritzie track down Brian and he'll
join us because we want to know if that
was a one take at least one see here I
like to bring in some of my Kevin's
famous chili the trick is to undercook
the onions everybody is going to get to
know each other in the pot he's serious
about this stuff and up the night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
Tomatoes I toast my own ancho chiles for
those who can't see they dumps an entire
pot on the floor of the the office so
he's trying to pick it up with paper
manila like a a folder there let's bring
in Brian Brian Bumgardner
best known as Kevin on the office I
Brian thanks for joining us give us the
background on that scene on the office
well first off good morning yeah yeah
great Brian great oh good it was just
some crazy writer with this bizarre idea
of total failure by heaven and the idea
I mean this thing that's so incredibly
sad about it is this is the thing that
he's most proud of in the entire world
and he ends up looking like the biggest
idiot ever we had that day also I got to
as two stories for you on the filming of
that day they had you know there was
this nondescript office II grey carpet
that we had in the office for whatever
ten years and they had literally cut a
whole other insert to put down on the
floor to replace the carpet for all time
and I think they had three of them so we
had three takes that we could do one
take
damn one tech that's in that's it
sometimes that's all you need you know
when you give the glory that's all you
need you know what I'm saying but did
they tell you to kind of slip in it
because you're cleaning up did they tell
you how to clean it up no no I mean I I
mean I we discussed what could happen
but you know no one know no one had done
a trial run on this carpet about what
would happen I mean it was an enormous
amount of chilli like a lot of chilli
I will there's a there is a I don't care
there babe Hormel chili can is what was
in that deck okay
so I actually have a very nice dinner
that night at Mastro's down in Beverly
Hills pre-planned and we shot that not
unsurprisingly at the end of the day in
case there was this gigantic mess and
they had to cut out the carpet you know
literally redo the carpet so we keep
doing takes so I was the only actor
still on said nobody everybody else is
gone and I get done I'm filthy
we shower me like I've got all these
people like handing me time and it's
coming out from everywhere right because
I'm like rolling at it so I get to
master as I'm super excited about this
all I could do is smell chili like I
can't get it all I can't get it off me
like it's just it's everywhere like in
my under my finger now me it's just
horrid the best line video is when you
you sure to go oh like when you rule his
the tragedy of it all oh yeah he was
just so proud it was just so proud and
rightfully so man yeah you know we miss
Kevin we do well thank you you know
maybe he'll be back someday
who knows is there a chance - is there a
chance - okay I thought we had breaking
news like the Hollywood Reporter might
be quoting us here yeah no not yet
we'll see
you don't know it out this way I know
somebody at NBC wants to do I'm sure
there's an executive there no yeah yeah
wouldn't that be a great idea and then
that becomes the big story I mean
they're doing Roseanne for goodness
sakes yeah and you know there's a few of
them that are being brought back now hey
I'm great
yeah Will and Grace yeah we could bring
back the office all right thanks for
joining us is always Brian we appreciate
it
hey happy chili day and we'll talk to
you soon all right that's Brian bum
Gardner he's so it was Kevin on the
office for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]